at the end of 1929 the Kremlin decreed
that millions of peasants from
individually owned farms would be forced
into agricultural collectives or
kolkhozes seen in the eyes of the
Politburo has pliant providers of Soviet
agricultural needs in defiance of the
facts so they theologists hammered out
an appropriate Marxist terminology to
explain what was going on throughout
grain producing areas it was said
resistance to this scientific scheme was
being organized by so-called rich
peasants or cool acts with his customary
brutality their force fell and decreed
the liquidation of the kulaks as a class
Stalin like this idea of like group
guilt that was a major theme for Stalin
like that man I really didn't have to
have to pay attention to you as an
individual I could just decide if you
were a doctor engineer or a Kulak her a
German or whatever ethnic racial or
educational division happened to
characterize my particular target at the
time and didn't matter if you were
guilty as an individual that whole
notion never even obtained it was class
guilt it mattered and if you were in one
of those classes well we were better
without you and of course the nature of
the class just changed constantly but it
was perfectly logical thing to think if
you believed in like historical
determinism if your parents were rich
burgeois what was the probability that
you're going to be a useful part of the
workers collective be easier just to get
rid of you ahead of time so you didn't
cause too much trouble
so then you think about these cool acts
rich peasants who are these people like
when we get down to the individual level
so you go on a village village was full
of serfs like not 40 years before so
these are people just struggling out of
the feudal society right and you got
some people in there who've managed to
be successful enough as farmers which is
no easy thing to like have a house and
maybe hire one person and you know maybe
have a little extra food in the larder
and a few kind of material possessions
so these are successful people and so
you could say well they're the ones that
actually knew how to farm it's one
theory or you could say the reason they
had all this stuff was because they
stalled it from all the other people
right and then you think okay so I march
into town I'm a Soviet revolutionary and
I say hey guys you know those rich
people they stole everything they have
from you and then you think okay
which of you guys is going to listen to
that well it's not going to be the sort
of struggling people just underneath
them who are really trying to get ahead
right because that's where they're
hoping to get it's gonna be the
resentful and revengeful few who think
well the world is fundamentally unfair
and it's obvious that those sons of
bitches got what they want by stealing
it from me and here it turns out that if
I just go down the street and steal it
back well not only not only am I allowed
to do that but according to this new and
emergent ideology man that's the best
thing I could possibly do so then
multiply that story by several million
participants and you have like the first
five years of the Soviet empire and so
what do we have there the result was a
catastrophic onslaught on millions of
peasant households at first party
activists and local officials read
bullies right brutalized peasants
forcing them to surrender their
homesteads and their possessions
deportations arrests and killings soon
followed as terror generalized the
violence mounted to full-scale rebellion
in various places with regular troops
engaged for months for example
suppressing peasant uprisings resistance
took various forms usually reflecting
the hopeless desperate anguish of a
doomed population in the Ukraine there
are even women's rebellions spontaneous
uprisings of peasant women who attack
the local kolkhozes to demand the return
of confiscated farm products with a
colossal impact on the Soviet economy
peasants slaughtered their animals by
the millions rather than see them seized
for two years the fighting raged as the
dreadful process of decolonization
continued stellen order to further
assault on the recalcitrant peasantry
what conquest calls the terror of Famine
of 1932 Moscow rights conquest that's
from a book called the harvest of sorrow
knowingly decreed grain procurements
from the Ukraine and elsewhere exceeding
by far with the local population could
produce right which meant that everyone
who lived there was forced and ordered
to deliver more grain than they had ever
grown communist brigades roamed the
countryside forcing agriculturalists to
discourage the little they had been able
to produce under conditions of
vier dislocation grain sat unused in
state reserves while the local
population starved
[Music]